MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
VIC FRYZEL: Hello, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Vic, and this is Claudio.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Hi.
VIC FRYZEL: Today, we're going
to be taking you through how
to get started quickly
using Python in the
Google Drive SDK.
So we have a quick
start sample.
The link to the sample code that
we're going to be talking
about today is going to
be along the bottom
of the screen here.
So just take a look at that link
at any point throughout
the video, and you can see
the code that we're
going to walk through.
Our goal today is to get through
running the sample in
10 minutes or less.
You think we can do that?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I
think we can do it.
Let's see how to do it.
Let's show my computer here.
The first thing you need to do
it if you want to write a
Python application that
integrates with the drive API
is to install the Python Client
Library that we provide.
To do it, it's a very
easy command.
You can use Easy Install, which
is a standard way to
install Python libraries.
And you pass the parameters
dash, dash upgrade, so that it
either installs the library or
updates an existing one.
So we do this.
Of course, you might need
root privileges.
So I'm going click
password here.
It's going to download
the library.
I already have the latest
version so I'm done.
If you don't have that, and you
run this command, it will
just download the library from
the website and install it,
and you'll be ready to go.
To get started quickly, we
provide you with this quick
search sample.
We have one for each of these
supported languages.
They will be available in the
documentation in our Drive SDK
documentation very soon.
But the Python one I'm going
to use today is a already
available in this short link.
You'll be seeing an overlay.
So in my project folder,
I have two files.
Let me show to you.
I have drive.py file, which
is my source code, and
document.txt, which is a text
file that I'm going
to upload to Drive.
So let me just show document.txt
just contains a
single line of text.
But this can be a text file.
This can be anything you want
to upload to Drive.
Let me show you the other one
that's there, the py file.
I have it open already.
It's a standard Python
command line sample.
So today, we're going to show
you how to write a command
line application, not
a web application.
The basic difference is
in the authorization.
So let me show you
how this works.
And then, we will go through
the code line by line.
So let me go back
to the terminal.
So I'm here.
I just run it with
python drive.py.
What I get is the first
step of the
authorization, OAuth flow.
Since this is not a web
application, we have no
browser in the command line.
So we have to manually copy and
paste this link and open
it in our browser to start
the OAuth flow.
We will get back to
this as soon as we
look at the code again.
VIC FRYZEL: So a real
application being run from the
command line would do something
like spawn a
browser, collect a token, and
then store the token in the
user's home directory or
something like that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And, of
course, a web application will
just take you to this page
and handle it directly.
But this is the easiest way
to run the OAuth flow.
And this is very easy to do
in command line sample.
It takes about a few
lines of code.
So we decided to show
this as that.
So I got this URL.
And I can go to my browser.
But before I can do anything
like that, we have to generate
our credentials.
So the first step that we have
to do before we can run the
sample is to create our
credentials in the Google API
console, which is available at
code.google.com/apis/console.
You might probably have
a project already.
I have none.
So I'm going to create
a project.
When I create a project, I have
a list of services that I
can enable or disable.
And what I need is
the Drive API.
So I'm going to enable
the Drive API--
done.
So the Drive API is enabled.
I have to get my credentials,
which are client
ID and client secret.
To do that, I go to the
API Access tab.
And I need to create an
OAuth 2.0 client ID.
So it's a step-by-step guide.
I click on that.
I need to specify my product
name, which might be Drive
Quickstart.
If I want, I can add
a product logo.
I don't have one.
It's not required.
So I click Next, and I have
to specify what type of
application this is.
So this can be a web
application.
This can use service account.
In my case, this is going to be
an installed application,
which is a command
line application.
So I select.
The installed application
is not for Android.
It's not for iOS.
It's a standard command
line application, so I
create a client ID.
With that, I get this box
with my new credentials.
So I have client ID and
client secrets.
And I need to use them
in my Python code.
So let me put those credentials
I can copy this, go back
to my source here.
And if you open the source code
with sharing we have two
placeholders here for client
ID and client secrets.
So I can replace this, and I can
replace the client secret.
Of course, the client secret
must be secret.
So remember, when you do this,
don't share the client secret
with anyone.
And of course, as soon as we're
done with this, we're
going to revoke these
credentials, so no one can use
these credentials and
impersonate me in this
application.
So now, my application is
really ready to run.
So let's try again.
Let's start again.
So let's go back
to the console.
Let's cancel that
and start again.
VIC FRYZEL: Why do we
have to cancel that?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Because when
I ran that, I didn't put
my credentials first.
So let me try again.
So I get a new URL.
I do what I said I was
going to do before.
Copy that, this URL, go back
to my browser, and start--
go to that page.
Let me make this bigger.
And this is the standard
OAuth flow.
So this is saying that the Drive
Quickstart application,
which remember, is the name
of the application I just
created, is requesting
permission to view and manage
the files and documents I
have in my Google Drive.
If you want more details, you
can expand it and see that
that application can upload,
download, update files, and
everything.
So my application is basically
requesting access to
everything on Google Drive.
There are different scopes,
different permissions you can
run to your application.
What I'm using here to make it
easier is the full scope.
So this application is allowed
to do everything.
But remember, this might
be scary to the users.
So if you don't need some
features, you don't need to
request this scope.
You shouldn't request
this scope.
VIC FRYZEL: So for a list of
some probably better choices
in scopes, see the link in the
code that we provided, which
goes to the documentation and
talks about each individual
scope that you can request.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
So I'm fine with application.
I know the developer, which
is me, so I can unlock the
system's application.
I click on it, and what
I get is that code.
Remember, this is the flow
that you get when the
application is installed.
It's not a web application.
In a web application, this code
will be sent directly to
your web application.
In this case, we have
a command line.
And we have no web server, so
I need to copy this code, go
back to the app, put the same
code in my command line app,
and as soon as I do and press
Enter, my application will be
authorized.
What the application does--
and I will show the
code in a minute--
is that the application will
take the other file that is in
the same folder called
document.txt, upload it to
drive, and then print all the
metadata we get back from
Drive on the screen.
It's very, very rough, not a
great URI, but just a sample
application.
So I press Enter.
And now the application
is performing upload.
And what I get back is this JSON
structure that is what
the API returned
after my code.
And this JSON structure has a
lot of metadata information
about my file, including a
download URL, so that now
users can download the
file from here in
file size, in bytes.
This is a very small file.
It's 24 bytes.
What kind of document
it is, it's a file.
It can be a folder.
It can be other type of files,
some labels, whether the
document is in Trash, it
is started, and so on.
In MIME type, this is a text
file, so the MIME type is
going to be text plain, , when
it was modified who's the
owner, and so on, all
the information you
need about this file.
So the application worked.
Let's see how it does
what it does.
VIC FRYZEL: We also did that
in less than 10 minutes.
That was pretty impressive.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But without
explaining properly.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, sure.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Let's see
how we can explain it.
So the application is a
Python application.
It starts with some imports.
You need to import some
libraries to use it.
So basically it's the client
library you downloaded.
Then we have our credentials,
which are the ones we took
from the APIs console and
generated them from the APIs
console a few minutes ago.
Then, we have the OAuth scope,
which is the type of
permission we are asking
to the users.
So as Vic said, at this
link, developers.googl
e.com/drive/scopes, you can see
all the developer scopes.
There are more restrictive ones,
and they might be better
for your application.
Then we have the name of the
file we want to upload, which
in our case is document.txt.
And these five lines here are
the ones we need to perform
the OAuth flow.
You want to explain
what this does?
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah.
So we offer a number of helper
classes with the client
libraries to make OAuth
easier to implement.
We use one of them here, which
is the OAuth 2.0 web server
flow class.
And all this really does is
provide a handler for making
OAuth requests.
So here, we create the flow,
and then we also get the
authorized URL in
the next step.
And that's going to be the URL
that you're going to have the
user copy and paste into
their browser.
Once the user copies and pastes
that URL, they're going
to click Allow Access.
And then they're going
to get a code back.
So the code is something
else that we have to
plug into the flow.
So we ask the user with
the raw input line to
paste in the code.
And then we take that, and we
exchange that code for a
refresh token and
an access token.
Once we have those, those are
actually stored in the
credentials object.
And the credentials objects is
what we're going to use to
authorize our upcoming requests
to the Drive API.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
There's something we can add
about this OAuth flow.
So whenever you go through
this flow, you get this
refresh token and
access token.
But every time you run the
application, the same
application, you have to go
through this flow again and
again and again.
Of course, this is not what
the user would expect.
So we could add some logic here
to sort the credentials
we got, then reuse them if they
are already available.
This is what the library does.
So if you use the client
library, you have a very easy
way to use some file storage
to sort your credential and
reuse them when needed
and only trigger
this flow when needed.
But we're not doing it, because
this way, it's just
easier to understand.
But, of course, in your
application, it should take
care of that.
So we use our credentials to
authorize the HTTP LIB object,
which is what we used to
send HTTP requests.
And that is all we need to
build a Drive service.
So using the client library,
what do you have to do to
build a service whatever
the service is?
In our case, it's Drive,
but it can be Google+.
It can be any other API
service we have.
You just need to specify what
the service name is, which is
Drive, and a version.
In our case, we're using
Drive API version 2.0.
So the name of the
version is v2.
And then we pass the
authorized HTTP
object that we have.
So that's one line to line to
instantiate the service.
And then we have to
upload a file.
This is what we want to do.
And in order to do that, we
have first to define some
metadata about the file, which,
of course, you can
somehow automate.
We have them hard coded here.
So whatever the file is in my
local file system, its title
on Google Drive will always
be my document.
Its description will always be a
text document, and MIME type
will be text plain.
But, of course, you should make
this different according
to what file you're passing.
And we're using a media file
upload class to read the
content of the file
from the disk.
These two parts together, so the
media body, which is the
content of the file, and the
body which is metadata, are
used to send an insert request
to the files resource.
So to insert a file on Drive,
you only need a single line of
code, which is this.
So you get the files resource
from the Drive service.
The files resource has a number
of methods, including
Insert, or Get, or
List, or Update.
In our case, we want to
create a new file.
So we call Insert.
And you have to pass the body
of the object, which is the
metadata, and the media body,
which is the content.
And then you call Execute.
And that's it.
The last line in our file is
just used to show some results
to the user.
VIC FRYZEL: Which is what
prints the Unicode
representation.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
It prints the JSON
representation.
Yeah, and if you want to see if
we actually did something,
we can go to my Drive account
and see that, hopefully, my
document is here.
It was updated--
well, modified a couple of
minutes ago, because we just
uploaded it.
It's a text document.
It can be open with the Google
Drive Viewer, which realizes
that this is just
a text document.
So it opens the content
here in this Viewer.
So the file is here.
It's called My Document, as you
know, because we selected
that as the title.
And its text content is here.
VIC FRYZEL: So let's pull
out the code again.
And then, we'll go through a
few ways in which we could
improve this code for
real-world use.
So as Claudio said before,
definitely cache the
credentials that you get back
so that the user only has to
run through this process once.
If you want to get really
advanced, you could spawn your
own web server in Python and
then set a redirect URI that
is like the local web server,
and then automatically open up
a browser on the user's behalf
that automatically goes to the
authorization URL.
And then once the user clicks
Allow Access, they would be
redirected to the local web
server to collect the code.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Remember, if
you do that, you have to go
back to the APIs console and
generate credentials for a web
application.
Let me go back to that.
So in the APIs console, we have
these credentials for an
installed application.
You can have as many credentials
as you want.
So we can create another
client ID.
And this time, say it's
a web application.
And what we have to specify here
is the redirect URI on my
application.
So I don't know.
This might be my application
running on Claudio.com.
So this will be the redirect.
So I can create a client ID.
And the redirect URI will be
claudio.com/OAuth2callback.
Of course, you can change it.
This is just the conventional
URL we have, but you can
change it by going
to Edit settings.
So I can say that the redirect
URI might be--
I don't know--
Redirect, and update it.
VIC FRYZEL: If you don't have
a domain to go to, a valid
redirect URI for installed
applications is always going
to be a local host, which
means if you spawn a web
server on the same system that
you're running this command
line application, you can
actually redirect back to that
local system.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Just remember
that the redirect URI
must match exactly what
you have in your code.
So if you have a specific
port number, you
have add it as well.
So if your redirect URI is on
http://localhostport3000, you
have to write it like that.
VIC FRYZEL: Exactly, yeah.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: If there's a
trailing slash, you have to
add a trailing slash.
If it's HTTPS, you have
to specify it here.
Of course, you can have
more than one.
More than one redirect
URI is allowed.
So maybe your server works on
both HTTP and HTTPS, so you
can add two lines and have one
HTTP and one on HTTPS.
And they're both allowed.
VIC FRYZEL: In the real world,
though, unless you're
redirecting the local
host, you should
always be using HTTPS--
always--
to make sure that the code
doesn't get leaked in between
in transit back to the user.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Just since
we're talking about redirect
URIs, even when you create an
installed application, you
still have redirect URI.
But that has a special value,
which is this string here,
which is defining the
OAuth 2.0 standards.
You don't have to remember.
This will be added for you
automatically, and you don't
have to specify in your code.
VIC FRYZEL: So that's just the
out-of-band redirect URI,
which means there's no
redirect essentially.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
so in our code, we
didn't specify it.
So the default value is
that it's out-of-band.
VIC FRYZEL: There's some other
ways you can improve this.
When setting the file name
variable, you could collect
this from sys.argv in Python,
like a command line argument.
Or you could prompt the user for
it to make the utility a
little bit more useful and
easier to use over time.
Some other things you might be
able to do are take some of
the metadata on the command
line or just assume some
defaults, like maybe set the
title to document.txt or the
file name of the file.
Try to guess the MIME type of
the file more intelligently.
Don't always set it
to text plain.
There are a lot of utilities in
Python to do this already.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, and
again, obviously, you can use
the extension to do that or
other way more advanced ways
to recognize what type
of file it is.
VIC FRYZEL: So a common question
that people might
have is when writing a command
line program to use the Drive
API, how are you supposed
to securely
store your client secret?
And it's not always so simple in
a Python script as pasting
in the client secret.
In many languages, actually,
that's quite
difficult to manage.
So you could do something like
store the client secret in a
web application on something
like Google App Engine and
then have the command line
application query that from
Google App Engine so that you're
not storing your client
secret here in plain
text all the time.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And then, of
course, you can make this
application more useful by
adding more commands.
So as I said, this
does insert.
But you have different methods,
all the methods you
can see in our documentation.
And so you could replace and
start with, let's say, List,
to get the list of all your
documents or to get a specific
document and so on.
VIC FRYZEL: So Claudio, where
would people find
documentation about that?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Documentation
for the Drive
SDK is available at
developers.google.com/drive.
And all the samples, including
this one, will
be available there.
We already have a more complex
Python sample in the
documentation.
That sample is for a web
application that uses App
Engine and is more complicated
than this.
It does a lot more.
It's a complete text editor
that saves and reads files
from Drive.
But we will also add this very
easy quick start sample, so
you can start with something
in five minutes.
VIC FRYZEL: So we recommend that
you take a few minutes,
walk through, copy and paste
this code, and see if you can
get it running for yourself.
Once you get this running,
expand it a little bit, get
comfortable, and then move on
to the example application
that we provide in
the documentation
that Claudio mentioned.
We call it Doctor Edit.
It's just a full-on
web text editor.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And so we
also have these research
samples from many
other languages.
Maybe in one of the future GDL
sessions, we might go through
all of them and see how they
work, how to set up the
environment for the
other languages.
So right now, we have ready
Java, well, Python you've seen
in here, and PHP, Ruby,
and dot NET.
So we can show all of them one
by one so that you might learn
how to set up the environment
for each of them.
VIC FRYZEL: So we like to hear
your feedback about what you'd
like to see more frequently.
So if you're really into Java,
tell us, and we'll do
something similar
to this in Java.
Maybe someday, we'll walk
through the text editor
application in detail and show
you how the code works there.
If you have any questions, be
sure to post them on YouTube.
We do read those.
I don't think that there are any
questions at the moment.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And remember,
any time you still
have technical questions, we're
always on Stack Overflow
with the Google-Drive-SDK tag.
We read all the questions
there.
And we're very active there.
And not only us, but a lot of
developers are there, and they
can already answer
many questions.
So feel free to get in touch
with us on Stack Overflow,
comment on this video,
or on Google+.
We are also very active there.
OK.
I think--
VIC FRYZEL: I think that's it.
I don't think we have any
questions at the moment.
So yeah, just post on
Stack Overflow.
I guess that does
it for us today.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
Yeah, I think that's it.
Thank you everyone
for watching us.
Hope you find this useful.
And see you next time.
VIC FRYZEL: Bye.